here we go there's frankie ferrari
very good passer sets up keegan murray
and welcome to the nba there you go
murray deeper three still easy range
i mean that's two feet behind the line
[Applause]
and bouier picks murray clean
[Music]
has it wiped off the window
[Applause]
paris bass gets stripped by murray he's
got pip in the beat he'll rumble inside
and lay it out
see his defense here pick bass clean
just now if you have a green
murray gets it back
he's got mccoy on him he's got the size
advantage fading away and connecting is
keegan murray
[Music]
i think eventually you'd get it right
the run out dunk it's keegan murray
[Applause]
vanquiero's defense
has been suffocating on keegan murray so
far let's just say it
murray got loose
and made good use of the opportunity
slips out to the corner
for three okay
okay
great play three-point game doors great
execution
and the steal
they can tie it with the three murray
[Applause]
a murray yes
in the desert
casual casual little entry pass here
tip ball
and mr murray
wow ferrari gonna set the table here
murray slips out drives the closeout got
it big time move as you alluded to
keegan murray nick's coming up next
against the bulls nick's trying to get
to the playoffs murray back door lays it
home
and one
took the hit too
murray read that well he's got man to
beat and he throws it down
he's just got a great deal omarouji
six on the shot clock murray attacking
high off the glass that he could have
got the whistle on that one again
another play
and then keegan murray he's not flashy
but boy is he effective
and so he can just play to his strengths
the shot blocking the rebounding the
plate making and he's still going to be
able to score some that's a terrific
finish here if he can murray but i'll
tell you
110 left in the first quarter
murray all the way in with the foul
so simple you can see why chris
middleton
is his favorite player for sure a lot of
similarities in
how they play and when the light clicks
again you gotta remember chris middleton
started his career in detroit oh
okay right on point keegan
but uh check out this murray
three-pointer we see a lot of that stack
we'll be back with more summer league
basketball
[Music]